[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم قوات الاحتلال تقتل
فلسطينيه من المسافه صفر مشاده كلاميه
شرقيه رام الله
مع حمله اعتقالات الاسرائيليه في مناطق
متفرقه من الضفه الغربيه
نحو 70 قتيلا في تحطم طائره ركاب
السلطات تتحدث عن وجودنا جينا واعلن
التشكيل لجنه التحقيق في الحادث وقالت ان
الطائره تسقطت اثناء استعدادها للهبوط وان
قائدها لم يبلغ برج المراقبه بوجود اي
مشاكل عدد قتل القصر الروسيه على ديني برو
في ارتفاع اوكرانيا اعلنت رصد مزيد من
السفن الروسيه بالبحر الاسود في حاله تاهب
قتاليه بعد استخدامها في الهجمات
الصاروخيه امس بينما اكد بوتن ان العمليات
العسكريه اوكرانيا تمضي به ايجابياته وكما
هو مخطط لها
واسطه ازمه سياسيه متفاقمه في تونس اتحاد
الشغل يحذر من انتفاضه شعبيه بسبب مسماه
السياسات غير الوطنيه للحكومه المتعاقبه
وهيئه الانتخابات تمضي قدما لاجراء الدور
الثاني من الانتخابات التشريعيه بنهايه
الشهر الجاري الى اللقاء